you know when I was six I stuck a fork
into an electrical outlet because I was
curious I think that that was the
beginning of exploring the force that
was outside myself that could have
physical effects on me and my brain and
my reality I think Andrews work blends
this beautiful use of media and
technology and and design into these
exciting moments of storytelling time is
Nature's Way of keeping everything from
happening all at once
Amanda Schneider I'm a director designer
performer writer of nervous system which
has been developed here at MIT cast
[Music]
being here at MIT has been different
than other places we've been to most
places our venues that we load in and
out of they program a season and we come
in we do the work and we load out being
here is sort of more of a research
laboratory we're thinking about things
differently here when I think about the
work I think about the work in not just
this show but about a trajectory of
shows and so a first show that we made
sort of explores parallel universes and
perception and then a second show
explores shared consciousness and what
happens to a human body up there dies
initial Springs out into what is reality
and how do we interface with it some of
the goal is to sort of get the audience
to question what is real we concentrate
more on making you feel a thing or
perceiving your own perceptions or
seeing yourself see like realizing that
you are a being who has perceptions or
realizing that your own mind who thinks
what we try to do is use technology in
service of manifesting humanity I would
say to expose the technology then strip
it away and then be left with human
beings in a room together this artist in
residency program here sort of gives us
this major advantage over over the other
things that are out there because not
only do we get to bring in artists that
we think are really important in the
current contemporary world we get to
expose our students to that kind of work
and they get to experience it firsthand
so even when we see a show at another
institution
we see the the facade of the show but we
don't get to go backstage and then find
out how it works he was using tools that
are are really not that different than
what other theater artists are using but
he's using him in sort of a new and
exciting way so this is I guess my way
of actually interfacing with a mass of
people and sort of saying hey right does
anyone else experience life like this
like and doesn't it feel like this and
that that's what I think Theatre in its
essence actually does is say is say
those same things and I think that I
just happen to go about it in a
different way